danke viel mal für all die Kommentare
und die Gedanken zu Meer Reportage
schanengleichheit im Schweizer
Schulsystem ich habe die Reportage
gemacht will ich als Jugendliche mich
immer wieder allein gefühlt hab und ich
hab wssen ob sich da hat in richtig
schance gichheit und es schint so dass
es nicht wirklich anders ist als das was
ich erlaubt hab es gibt verschiedene
stützungsangebot auch vom kantonus das
finde ich cool aber
es seeht immer so aus als wenn wir
einfach Glück haben muss dass man zu de
Angebot kommt oder halt aktiv werden
muss wie bitan und die hilf muss g
suchchen es git wo das anders gesehen
z.B du Andreas schriebst jeder hat in
der Schweiz die gleichen Chancen aber
nicht jeder nüzt auch seine Chancen und
diese ewigen Ausreden nerven langsam
Merc dass du geschrieben hast und dass
Du Dich mit dem Thema
auseinandersetz es bin ja nicht nur ich
wo das behauptet dass ees Bildungsystem
keine Chan gichheit hat das S
aufchl zir Bildungsdirektion hat s
2003 Längsschnittstudie durgeführt und
die komm unter anderem zum ergabnis dass
Jugendliche mit privilegiertem
Hintergrund Zahal höcher
Wahrscheinlichkeit hab ins gimit als
Lehrer zufangen kann im Vorhinein sagen
das Kind mit privilegiertem Hintergrund
eher ins gem gönt als Kind wo sozial
benachteiligt sind und da GT um die gich
leistige und Note es hab sich eben auch
l gemet wo e genau die unglichichheit
erfahren Hand und erlbt Hand was es
Punkte ausbildig und Schul heißen kann
wenn wir uner sozial schwachere Schicht
Isabel ber
schriebt das kom mir bekannt vor allem
das mit dem wenn ter das hät hät
privatschul K dann hät ihr bessere betre
betreu ja ich kann sber l von M umfald
waso entsch
privatschul und nicht das ja und nicht
die Schul wo ich gangen bin w sie
einfachfen ist vielleicht der B Weg für
sie und schon damals nicht gewüst das
ist jetzt W ich mit Meer Familie nicht
Leist will mir einfach das geldt nicht
und mir dufwiesen sind auf das
bildsystem vor der Schwiz der nächste
Kommentar bestätig auch wenn Lehrperson
dich istuft dann stellt das auch weiche
fürs spätere le und das prägt du
wortiger Wolf schrieb habe gerade eine
Lehrstellen Suchende Tochter aus der
real mit wirklich guten Noten traurig
was man da erlebt auf der
Lehrstellensuche vertrösten falsche
Versprechungen Bewerbung wird gleich
aussortiert Bewerbung wird nicht mal
richtig angeschaut steht eben real auf
den Zeugnissen ja eigentlich hät min
Note gelanget fürs höchste Niveau vor
der Oberstufe aber mein Lehrer hat das
Gefühl ist viicht besser wenn ich ein
Smoo und langsamer Start in der
Oberstufe was ich irgendwie noch
verstanden und ich bin
dann wordde wo ich viel K auch real
bezeichnet wird und ich habe GewSt dass
mir viele weg da n off ver steh
das dass ich dann für viele Betrieb und
Firmen n im frag die für lehrstell das
jetzt nicht nur subjektiv empfinde das
bestätigt Experte wie der Bild Stefan
wter von der Uni Bern und die bekannte
erziswissenschaftlerin Margret Stamm
Realschüler g die lehrstell finde wenn
gut die der Schul sind und die gich
leistige Hand wie Schüler vi diskutiert
immer akademisch Weg brucht dual schrieb
studieren ist gut und recht doch sollte
hier in der Schweiz wieder mehr Fokus
auf die Lehre gesetzt werden es können
nicht alle studieren es stimmt es m
nicht studieren aber es s all die gich
Chanen
und Herkunft abestuft werden ich finde
le super ich habe selber le gemacht und
ich
schätze duale bildigsystem von der
Schwiz aber man nicht der
Junge Kind vfang sag das für sie die
einzige Option le ist will sie in der
Familie keine Unterstützig
Hand ganz viel hab geschrieben wie sie
die Schul sie gegangen ist und dass sie
gern unterstützeig K hättet du anix
schriebst hatte eine ähnliche Erfahrung
nach der Primarschule wurde ich in die
Realschule eingestuft mir fählte
schlichtweg die Lernmethodik als mein
Stiefvater in mein Leben gekommen ist
hatte mir die
lmtig beigebracht und dann ging es Berg
auf mit den Noten von der Primarschule
Hilfe bekommen
nein chikor schribt ich hatte leider
Pech mit meinen Lehren ich wurde auch
minder eingestuft und war total
enttäuscht heute habe ich habe ich einen
Bachelor in umweltchen Wesen und einen
in Energie und Umwelttechnik man darf
den Glauben an sich nicht aufgeben und
weitermachen egal was ihr irgendein
Lehrer sagt also ich glaube das ist
enorm wichtig aber es ist natürlich auch
schwer wenn man jung ist und so niemand
da ist wo dich
glaubt drum braucht mir Unterstützig und
bei mir ist es so gie dass ich zum Glück
genau gewüst hab was ich will werde und
Lehr wo da sind
wo wo mir nicht gesagt dass ich es nicht
schaffen und drum hab ichrieb geh zum
einfach wirklich machen und m viele hab
Potential und wenn jemand fördert dann
löst se auch ab normalwies ist es so
dass Kinder ja immer gern lernet und am
besten n wenn es mit Spaß verbunden ist
aber jetzt mus man sich überlegen was
ist da passiert wenn es Kind seid es lö
mir ab ich bin doch so oder so schon
dumm für das das ist ja genau das wo B
der J passiert ist wo im Film vor ist
und das finde ich mega
schad aber es geht auch natürlich Stig
wo geschrieben Hand dass Reportage
Problem aufbaust will Schwiz nach wie
vor es versstem hat z.B schebt der Ros
Baumann ich finde die Chancengleichheit
in der Schweiz immer noch am höchsten
von allen Länden auf der Welt jammen auf
sehr hohem
Niveau Resultat
P Studie Leid ganz anders Schwiz ST im
Verglich zu Lander wo mit
verglich nicht so gut da Schwiz ist der
schit im bildingsystem wie hinter
Finnland und Kanada und eben auch hinter
Nachbar in östich da schribt
der vielleicht sollten sich Menschen
einfach eingestehen dass nicht
intelligentesten sind die Realität zu
missachten und zu träumen ist nicht
hilfreich ja es GT drum dass gewöse
anders beurteilt werdet als andere und
das finde ich nicht fair also
Jugendliche wo t gich leistet und dur ih
soziale Herkunft oder Vorurteil anders
bewertet werdet als privilegiert das SE
auch Studie vom Institut für
bildigsevolution od zür und dann haben
wir noch zum Schluss tasa wo offenbar
selber Lehrperson ist sehr berührend und
gut wieder daran erinnert zu werden dass
ich als lebperson die Kinder möglichst
wertfrei begleiten und nicht B
verurteilen sollte du hast mir besonders
viel Freud gemacht mit dem Kommentar und
allen andere merci fürs inl und wenn mir
so rck Reportage W dann abonniert doch
der
Kanal